now i would like to introduce um dr gus
kasulis
dr casulis is a professor of bioerology
and biotechnology in the department of
pathobiological sciences
and the director of the division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine
she is the director of the nih-funded
center in experimental infectious
disease research and the director of the
nih-funded louisiana biomedical research
network molecular and cell biology core
so please join me in welcoming dr gus
casulis
are you able to unmute your microphone
yeah now nice i'm muted that i couldn't
unmute it earlier it was blocked
um can you hear me now
yes we can hear you now okay great
okay um
thank you laura for the introduction um
i wanted to sort of update a little bit
uh what you said i'm also department
head in pathological sciences
and we are pleased here at the lsu
school of very medicine that we have two
additional centers
the lung biology center
that's led by dr um samitabhi giazilian
as well as a pre-clinical
cancer recovery
that's led by dr joseph francis
the molecular cores of both of those
centers as well as the previous center
infectious diseases
it's actually administered by
my division of biotechnology molecular
medicine with essential elements the uh
core facility gene lab that provides
next-gen sequencing and bioinformatic
analysis internally as well as in
collaboration with pine biotech but i'm
here to talk to you today about the
nonprofit organization which i represent
as the president
and laura can i share my slides
yes you should be able to share those
so you should be able to see i hope
my slides now
so the national association of idea
principal investigators is a
not-for-profit organization representing
all these centers
that are funded by the national
institute of health the national
institutes of general medical sciences
that includes more than 170 centers for
biomedical research excellence
that are funded by the kobe mechanism
24
of the inbred mechanisms as well as
multiple klinger translational centers
and other programs that are run through
the manpower
division capacity division of nhgms
so
the purpose of nappy is really to
promote the idea programs again we're a
not-for-profit
organization
that
is principally to foster interactions
and to promote research sharing
and
the website is the as shown here at
nappy.org
there's another very important
information
including resources and training
resources that we have made available
freely either through
participation of different programs
and also
through collaboration with pine biotech
and i really urge you to explore this
website and look at the opportunities
that we offer
in addition nappy
is
partnering with lsu
to manage the national
idea
conference that happens every two years
the next conference is called nisbri
it will be
the first week of october
and it will be virtual and it would uh
allow a glimpse of all these 23 states
and puerto rico programs the cobre the
embrys the ctrs the co-funded programs
as well as some of the specialized
programs we expect over a thousand
people to participate on the virtual
meeting
the contract has been awarded by nih to
lsu and nappy is collaborating with lsu
to manage this national uh meeting
uh the next meeting after that would be
2024 and 2026 in person in washington dc
the first meeting on 2022
will be virtual meeting
and
it will have a number of other resources
training as well as participation
of major companies
we hope google amazon ibm and others
so um the next slide this is the
leadership of nappy
i am the current president of nabi
and
these are the officers for the executive
committee we also do have a steering
committee
having four members representing the
different programs from each of the four
geographically uh different uh
portions of the country
south uh east west north
and uh we meet periodically to ascertain
how to promote better the interactions
with an aids and also with all our
constituents
um
of course as i reiterated uh to
reiterate now the mission of lab is to
provide leadership and communication for
the development promotion and
improvement of biomedical research
through the inbree calgary
entrepreneurship hubs this is a new
type of
program that has been developed to also
facilitate entrepreneurship within the
idea states and of course the ctr idea
programs the objectives is to focus
interact to foster interactions to
promote visual sharing to enhance the
visibility of the program to develop a
consensus of priorities and to identify
disseminate best practices and to
identify opportunities and develop
strategies to achieve the common goals
of the idea program one of the major
emphasis of nih as well as of the idea
program
especially through the inbree mechanisms
is really the training
of
a pipeline of investigators starting
from undergraduates to graduate students
to postdocs to faculty in data science
and bioinformatics so therefore one of
the major goals of nebby is to share
resources and provide avenues for
training in data science and
bioinformatics
through nepe as well as through the
individual components that represent the
idea
so
program
terms of the history of the idea program
it started in 1993
the purpose was to broaden the
geographical distribution of united's
funding for biomedical research and
behavioral research
it focuses on health-related research
and
the
reasoning is to enhance the
competitiveness of investigators
at
all institutions locating states which
the aggregate success rate for the
application age has been historically
been low if you look really at the um
trajectory of this program it's actually
quite amazing that the idea program has
achieved um the uh a number of different
important
thresholds including the graduation of
young investigators with r1 nationally
competitive applications at a younger
age and
with increased
success rate
even comparing all nih programs across
the board so
we are really to promote science and
create a pipeline of investigators
starting from undergraduates all the way
to faculty and hopefully through tenure
and
the promotional program grant funding
so this is the
this is the type of funding that has
been received so far in 2021 there were
396
million dollars allocated to the idea as
part of the overall budget the goal of
nappy is to facilitate in collaboration
with the epscor uh foundation as for
coalition uh up to one percent of the
nih budget to be targeted to idea
programs uh we're a little bit
below that at this point the projection
for 2022 is at 410 million dollars but
still under the projected or at least
the uh what do we wish which is uh one
percent of the total nih budget um mind
you for 23 states in puerto rico
practically half of the states
in in the country
this is the type of contributions
different programs highlighted only a
few programs but you can see north
dakota
more than half of the funding for all in
aids funding for that state comes from
the idea program in other states
solution a little bit more successful
it's a smaller portion but critically i
think this particular component here
facilitates a number of people that are
actually now nationally competitive are
able to compete and get traditional
categorical funding through competitive
awards uh beyond at the national level
so it's a very critical component of
what nih is doing these are the uh
principal components of the idea funding
the cobre programs the purpose of this
cobra is to graduate people with
independent funding
hopefully our one funding over a 15-year
period the inbury program it's only one
per state and that really focuses on the
pipeline from undergraduates all the way
to graduate and faculty i has a number
of primarily undergraduate institutions
and it has a critical component in
teaching mentoring and training in data
science and bioinformatics in fact one
of the principal course which is
mandatory all these programs is a data
science bioinformatics core right now
that we also have in our own program we
also have the clinica translational
research centers uh they're really sort
of uh
smaller uh clinical translational uh
centers the the ctsas as they're named
and these are really targeting the idea
stage for clinical and translational
research one important component of the
idea program is co-funding people
that go for our 15s or s10 applications
may
get a boost and get funded probably
within five percentile points uh through
co-funding between igms idea and the
categorical institute and of course the
new addition is the regional technology
transfer hubs sdtrs therefore
they're active right now there may be
additional ones coming up in the next
round of applications and the idea is to
really increase the number of sbirs stdr
grants that are funded in the idea
states since they're not really
participating uh to a large extent in
this particular pool of funding that
comes from federal sources
part of the idea networks is also the
use of cloud computing that you just
heard the stride program
for google and amazon and there are
special occasions and supplemental
funding for that
there are promotion of statewide
regional networks that
are promoted through a variety of
different ways beyond just the cprs and
this uh
involves a specific co-funding
coordinator that has been appointed for
its nic categorical institute
the original
hubs also have pilot programs and they
also teach fundamentals for technology
core directors
to promote
entrepreneurship
there are also supplemental fundings
that came to
increase connectivity between british
and kobric ctrs and so on we've been the
recipients of multiple of those
supplemental funding and part of the
idea is to connect all these idea
programs together
through regional centers and promote
collaboration among all the programs
and then of course there were
specialized programs because of the
pandemic the kobe 19 patient registry
cloud computing has already mentioned
and then there is nih wide research
initiatives that are also linked
to programs within a gms and the idea
program
this is the map of the idea states
as you see
they're all over the country and
the focus is to also bring those states
up to become competitive for nice
funding as well as other
federal funding
so
nappy
through its website
has a number of very important
activities
it funds idea uh undergraduate traveling
to washington dc for the meeting as well
for registration into our virtual misery
meeting in 2022 we have awards for
undergraduate graduate students that
will actually already have allocated to
our regional idea meetings to happen in
between the national nisbria meeting and
we were happy to award up to three
thousand dollars to individual
undergraduate graduate students and
assistant professors in each of those
regional meetings
that already have occurred
we
can have access to a diy databases and
recessed expertise through the nepi
website which is actually increasingly
populated with new information and
ultimately we do provide discounts to
virtual courses in that data science and
mathematics uh through variety of
programs but also through collaboration
with pinewood tech and through a
grant that we received from the tober
foundation that allows certain of these
scholarships as well as support for
certain seminars that we'll be promoting
in the national
nisbria meeting that will happen the
first week of october
uh part of the sponsored symposia was
the previous omics reset symposium that
happened uh the omics one august 21-22
we also have advertised and support
this omix symposium that
has been put together in collaboration
with find biotech that provides a thing
important information and all these
recorded sessions uh will be available
uh through the nepi uh website
that we have
so uh this is what uh i had to tell you
about
nappy i would certainly encourage you to
look at the nappy website
we are going into a major campaign to
organize this virtual meeting
originally it was supposed to be in
person in june however we only just
received the notice of award for nih for
the next three meetings so the next
meeting will be the first week of
october
um i believe october 4 5 and 6
it will be a virtual meeting and we hope
that the registration for this
particular meeting will open uh
hopefully within the next two to three
weeks
and i would urge all of you uh to
participate in this meeting because
you're going to see
the breadth of
of all the
research that is being
supported by the idea program
not only our inbree programs but also
the kobri's the ctrs
some of the specific networks that have
been funded by sgms for child health and
cancer and beyond that so
i will point you to that website and
epic website for more information as it
becomes available so uh thank you for
participating it's very important uh
activity that uh findbot tech in
collaboration with others has put
together and i look forward uh to attend
some of the
next sessions
and answer any questions that you may
have
laura
okay thank you very much dr kasoulis
that was a very informative talk
um we have one question for you
how can nappy members participate in the
educational resource development nappy
is doing
yeah so basically um
through the website there is a form for
any content that you have that you could
actually share if you're willing to
share it nepi will promote it we have
over a thousand people registered on our
automated emailing system that would
alert them of that resource
and
we are actually in the process of
mailing out to major providers which
includes google and others uh to
link some of their content uh through
our nepi website and potentially provide
some discounts or support as it has been
done with nih so i would urge you to
contact uh the nappy webmaster and let
us know you can let me personally know
what you may be thinking and i would be
happy to share it with you or point you
to the right
material
great thank you
another question so can faculties at
universities that aren't involved in
nappy get involved
yes actually the nappy website is really
uh pre uh accessible to all so all the
content
is available
and um
we
welcome any uh participation from
non-ideal states
that could share with us content or
information or resources obviously we're
trying to make this information
um uh for the most part free or heavily
discounted for our nappy members but
absolutely yes we welcome anybody to
through our nappy website to communicate
with us and offer advice material
whatever that may be
great thank you very much
well i don't think there are any more
questions for you so thank you very much
again for presenting